all right I also want to mention this
this is from uh variety before we get to
the comment section
it says at the height of the backlash
against JK Rowling over her views on the
transgender Community Harry Potter star
Daniel Radcliffe published an open
letter in which he proclaimed trans
women are women in a new interview with
Indie wire Radcliffe opened up about why
he decided to speak out publicly against
the author who essentially gave him his
acting career he said the reason I felt
very very much as though I needed to say
something when I did was because
particularly since finishing Potter I've
met so many queer and trans kids and
young people had a huge amount of
identification with Potter on that and
so seeing them hurt on that day I was
like I wanted them to know that not
everybody in the franchise felt that way
and that was really important
okay now even for even aside from the
fact
that he's totally wrong on the
transgender issue of course he's
completely wrong about that and he's you
know he's defending the transiting of
kids and he's wrong to do that
he also
just
even putting that aside
you you owe it to JK Rowling
to keep your stupid ungrateful mouth
shut actually you actually owe that to
her
um
because she did in fact give you her
your career like you wouldn't exist in
the industry like nobody would know your
name without her
so she gave you everything that you have
and so you actually owe it to her you
owe some loyalty to her
so see all these Harry Potter actors and
there were a few that didn't speak out
against her against JK Rowling there
might have been one or two that actually
defended her
and I think one of them died recently
and and the left was dancing on his
grave obviously
um
but most of the Harry Potter actors came
out against her
which again they're wrong on the facts
they're wrong about the issue
but also where where's the Loyalty how
about having some loyalty to a woman who
gave you your whole career your
everything that you have is because of
her about a little bit of loyalty for
that
now that doesn't mean that if someone is
your friend or if someone uh helped you
professionally that you can never under
any circumstances criticize them I mean
there might be something really horrific
they could do where you feel like you
need to speak out
but just jumping on a dog pile
on someone who again gave you everything
that you have
on top of you being wrong you're also a
disloyal rat
along with it
which is worth noting
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]